[MUSIC]
Our workplaces are killing us in several
ways.
Number one, they are working us to death.
Too many hours.
Hours have been shown to be related, for
instance,
to blood pressure in an almost monotonic
relationship.
Workplaces are killing us because they
stress us and absence of job control,
work-family conflict economic insecurity
is obviously stressful.
So the combination of working us to death
and
stressing us to death is what's killing
us.
We understand that people's minds effects
their bodies and
stress is, of course, a mental state and a
mental attitude.
So in some sense, it's not that surprising
that things that make you stressed,
nervous, anxious feel out of control would
have enormous physiological impact.
And that's what the epidemiological
literature has shown really for
a long time.
So our contribution and the research that
we did
was to take a bunch of stuff that was kind
of sitting there and put it together.
So there were studies of health effects of
various workplace stressors, and
there were estimates of the pre,
prevalence of various workplace stressors.
What we did is put this all together in a
big model to estimate the total
effects on population health and
healthcare costs.
[MUSIC]
What we found when we put all these data
together is that our best estimate is
that there are about 120,000 excess deaths
annually just in the United States and
close to $200 billion in excess healthcare
costs as a consequence
of what we call exposures to harmful
workplace conditions.
And those would be things such as economic
insecurity absence of health insurance,
shift work, work-family conflict, things
that either effect directly access
to healthcare like health insurance, or
put stress and strain on people.
[MUSIC]
So when you say, what is the worst, it
depends on the outcome.
It turns out death is cheap.
Once you die, your healthcare costs stop,
so the biggest contributors to
healthcare costs are what I would call
chronic stressors,
things like work-family conflict and
economic insecurity.
The single biggest factor affecting
mortality is
the absence of access to healthcare which
comes from not having health insurance.
So the causes of costs are a little bit
different than the costs of mortality.
Because mortality and costs are not
perfectly correlated.
Things like economic insecurity and
work-family conflict
had pretty large effects, not as big as
the absence of health insurance or
work hours, but almost as big.
So psychology matters as well.
[MUSIC]
Well, I think for people employees, they
need to understand that going
to places where they experience
work-family conflicts, shift work,
long work hours, economic insecurity,
don't get access to health insurance,
that this is more than just, you know,
something that's inconvenient.
This is something that actually affects
their well-being in a deep and profound
way, and they ought to take these factors
into account as they select their jobs.
For employers who are concerned about
healthcare costs,
they should worry a lot about the work
environment.
At the moment, employers worry mostly
about individual decisions, eating,
exercise, smoking, drinking, things like
that, or they worry about broad,
social policy issues, like how we pay for
healthcare in the United States.
A lot of their excess healthcare costs
come from what happens to people
every day in the work environment, and
almost everything that, is around
the work environment are things that
employers could fix if they wanted to.
[MUSIC]
Just as we have regulated secondhand smoke
exposure,
presumably public policy could do
something to,
intervene and not so much to regulate the
workplace.
But if you think about it,
what we're talking about is a form of
social pollution.
So, 50, 60 ,70 years ago, if I foul the
water or
foul the air, I did not have to pay for
the cost of that.
And so, if you had companies incur the
cost
of laying people off and making people
feel economically insecure,
if you had companies facing the costs of
not providing people health
insurance not providing people flexibility
to take care of their family obligations,
not providing justice and fairness, which
is another one of the workplace exposures,
then those costs would become internalized
to the employer, and
they would make better and more
economically rational decisions.
But at the moment, they just pass the cost
off to the larger society, so
therefore, they are not very concerned
about this.
Because at the end of the day if you think
about it
if an employee gets really sick or really
dies the, they drop out of the workforce,
and then they're no longer the employer's
responsibility at all.
So what we need to do with respect to
social pollution or human pollution,
it's what we have done in the past with
environmental pollution,
which is to have the employers see the
cost of their actions, so
they can make more intelligent and sounder
decisions.
[MUSIC]